dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I here this work
presents a learning-based method that is
able to take just a handful of photos
and use those to synthesize a moving
virtual character not only that but it
can also synthesize these faces from new
viewpoints that the AI hasn't seen
before these results are truly sublime
however hold on to your papers because
it also works from as little as just one
input image this will refer to as
one-shot learning you see some examples
here but wait a second
really just one image if all it needs is
just one photo this means that we can
use famous photographs and even
paintings and synthesized animations for
them look at that of course if we show
multiple photos to the AI it is able to
synthesize better output results you see
such a progression here as a function of
the amount of input data the painting
part I find to be particularly cool
because it strays away from the kind of
data the neural networks were trained on
which is photos however if we have
proper intelligence the AI can learn how
different parts of the human face move
and generalize this knowledge to
paintings as well the underlying laws
are the same only the style of the
output is different absolutely amazing
the paper also showcases an extensive
comparison section to previous works and
as you see here nothing really compares
to this kind of quality I have heard the
quote any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic so many times in my life and I was
like okay well maybe but I'm telling you
this is one of those times when I really
felt that I am seeing magic at work on
my computer screen so I know what you're
thinking how can all this wizardry be
done this paper proposes a novel
architecture where three neural networks
work together one the embedder takes
colored images with landmark information
and compresses it down
into the essence of these images to the
generator takes a set of landmarks the
crude approximation of the human face
and synthesizes a photorealistic result
from it and three the discriminator
looks at both real and fake images and
tries to learn how to tell them apart as
a result these networks learn together
and over time they improve together so
much so that they can create these
amazing animations from just one source
photo the authors also released a
statement on the purpose and effects of
this technology which I'll leave here
for a few seconds for our interested
viewers this work was partly done at the
samsung AI lab and skull tech
congratulations to both institutions
Keeler paper make sure to check it out
in the video description this episode
has been supported by weights and biases
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments in your deep
learning projects it is like a shared
logbook for your team and with this you
can compare your own experiment results
put them next to what your colleagues
did and you can discuss your successes
and failures much easier it takes less
than five minutes to set up and is being
used by open AI Toyota Research Stanford
and Berkeley it was also used in this
open a I project that you see here which
we covered earlier in the series they
reported that experiment tracking was
crucial in this project and that this
tool saved them quite a bit of time and
money if only I had access to such a
tool during our last research project
where I had to compare the performance
of neural networks for months and months
well it turns out I will be able to get
access to these tools because get this
it's free and will always be free for
academics and open-source projects make
sure to visit them through Wendie be
calm waa md be calm or just click the
link in the video description and sign
up for a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time